shenon is on Pace to make history in his
third season shenon is currently
averaging 21 points nine rebounds and
five assists and shooting over 56% from
the field the youngest players to
average 25 and five while shooting over
55% are Giannis and Kareem shenon is
only 21 also reminder he wasn't even a
top 15 pick so how did a guy people are
literally calling baby yic fall so far
in the draft well even the Rockets
weren't sure about shenon when they
drafted him 16th overall though he was a
talented scorer his defense was far from
Elite Additionally the 19-year-old from
Turkey spoke zero English yet according
to the Rockets GM despite not
understanding what the coaches were
saying shenon was quickly able to learn
every play at summer league and since
then with his tenacity and skill set he
has continued to show Houston that they
got the steal of the draft shagun
actually grew an inch in the offseason
and says that he has massively benefited
from the coaching and roster changes in
Houston as shingon keeps maturing and
the rockets keep improving they could
easily continue to shock the